um let's go next to daniel from nevada
daniel welcome yes
hello uh can you hear me yes i can
awesome um i've been trying to catch you
for months
well here we are let's make it
worthwhile
oh so
in
recent years
so so uh
there's big
stuff happening in in america and and
it's really bad but i feel like there's
stuff in other countries as well that
i i think needs more attention okay give
me an example um
so an example of
my
um i only know about this because my
best friend lucero so in the philippines
um there was this bill early this year
um
and the president led it lapsed into law
from 30 days of not signing it or
vetoing it
and it's called the social media or the
sim card and social media registration
act
and it
basically in in
the things it does is require
all
filipino citizens to one register their
legal name and id with a sim card if
they have it and daniel i hate to
interrupt you i just here's the thing i
want to say to you
for for the average american that's just
not a more important issue than the
domestic issues that we're dealing with
i don't i don't know about that issue
the registration of sim cards in the
philippines but it's not that's not like
my audience if i we do like a show about
here's issues facing the country
if i talk about that's not it's not more
important for people here it's just not
and i i don't deny that it's a relevant
issue
the well but the second part is is the
part that's
like really bad it requires the whole
country to dox themselves on social
media right you can't you cannot use
a username you have to use your real
name on your social media account okay
basically doxing them under penalty of
law with a penalty of minimum six years
imprisonment or two hundred thousand
pesos if that's as you describe that
sounds bad
but yeah from the perspective of the
united states where we've got a broken
health care system we're trying to
figure out how to prevent the rise of a
fascistic authoritarian maga right wing
we're trying to deal with all of these
different issues and and the environment
and all these different things
the fact that you've got to dox yourself
on social media in the philippines it's
i'm not saying that it's not important
to the people there but it's not really
an issue that in the us is going to get
a lot of attention
okay yeah it just it just is what it is
you know
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it there's always lots
of important issues it's just not um
that i just don't know that that is like
the perfect example of the issue that's
being missed in american media
necessarily let's take a very quick
break
if you're holding to talk to me don't
hang up because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkistconnect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect let's sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert green super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below